[Music]
all right so the the inward
spiral um it's not just
this so it's going to go in first
in and it starts to generate that bend
in this
elbow okay I'm I'm giving you elements
that you keep missing so I get that
tight do you feel that tightness in in
your body so here no no tightness you
see you want you want to take out the
slab and then then you have it okay so
that's how far you go so you you feel
there we are okay and I get that bend
and we won't do any movement just to
isolate it now okay and now what I want
to do is keep that bend in his arm so I
don't want to loose do you see I don't
want that so I keep that bend in his arm
and keeping it I turn his
elbow
so he he's here like that and what I'm
going to do is take this elbow turn it
this
way I'm not going to make I'm not going
to go like this for example his arms not
going to go like that so I'm not going
to do that and then this and then over
here I get a Bend boom and then I keep
that bend in his elbow
I'm really
turning his elbow or this stump right
here
boom
boom and hence I'm turning my stomp my
elbow elbow in I turn my
stum boom till you feel that tight
that's going to give you the bend you
want and then turn that bend
there it is turn
it so as I don't want his arm to extend
then the same thing I don't want my arm
to extend because you see it'll help
extend his arm so my body doesn't move
my my arm extension doesn't
move that's the same way though I I
can't go past you see so I can't go here
and then go like
this
boom yeah keep
it not here it'll extend his arm
okay boom it'll go a little pterodactyl
arm it extends his arm so you're task
with don't let his arm change the angle
on his
elbow all right let's try
that I'll give you another metric
okay so on this metric when I come
around and I do this if I turn my
elbow you're going to see that
my pinkies on top and thumbs on the
bottom
now I'm turning my elbow or all the way
boom over here this way just like you
you me
again Bo get your grip while punch you
in the
face all the way finish the movement
don't go here finish the
movement finish it finish the
movement okay so pinky up thumb down no
no no no definitely okay try it again so
don't don't have in your head what we're
doing just do what we're doing don't go
oh this is EO like how can it be EO I'm
on the line of attack how can it be
edaga his head's not there we're just
doing this fire spiral just so just do
it I'm not doing a technique okay so
when you're coming around here and
you're like oh I feel him and then just
see you made your hand go
around he's irrelevant it's just you
don't know the powder so you can't do it
when you're doing it by yourself you can
do it by
yourself right now he's just my my
metric okay so as I turn my
elbow Bo yeah there's pressure there it
doesn't matter I keep turning my elbow
I don't go here is where you're going to
feel the weight you see here no weight
when you come back around and turn his
elbow you're going to feel the weight
there it is okay don't start going
around it that his long arm and he has a
long
arm W keep your elbow where it is turn
your elbow no keep turning your
elbow
now the power source for the elbow is
your
quad so as my quad turns boom it goes
back and then it comes
[Music]
back
in this way this way
five so that
little you feel here where you want to
go around
it you just move your quad into
it the the energy the resistance will be
yin to how much power I can put in this
CL
Bo so I want you to put your attention
here
[Music]
w now you can bring your mind back and
you'll see that my elbow is still doing
the same that we did before
now okay try
it you elbow power is is very powerful
it's very powerful anything closer to
your core your Center Line is going to
be more powerful you see that you see
there's ioka all the time they get these
little pterodactyl arms you see the
little pterodactyl
arms you got it and they go like
that okay but that is not going to
generate the
energetics do do you understand it's not
going to do
it
so I know it looks for
example you're like okay you go and I'm
here like this and you go that looks
greater that looks like you burent your
elbow you see
or you unwind
it and it's just katat dirty it just
spun itself around you get it it's not
that I bend my elbow I'm not going like
this okay so I keep katatori which we
know is I hang there it is that's my
natural
armband I keep katata Ding and now just
wind
it until it can't go anymore you see and
it it gets that bend but I didn't bring
my arms or my muscles in or out nor
relax nor tense okay and then the same
thing as I go around I don't come back
to
here because now I'm going to turn the
elbows so the elbows turned but it's
still katata dirty so as I'm turning my
elbows and I'm here
it might look to you like this is more
bent but if I unwind
it and I put my body
back it's just
katata okay so it doesn't change either
at the
end oh you're like it looks like no I'm
not you just it just wound itself more
and you unwind
it put your body back and you're in
katata
okay and I want
full conditioning so I go all the this
way you go all that way to condition and
so the same reason I go B all this way
all that way to
condition okay try it
again
all right so now as you're going to H me
or technique you're going to use this
you combine this pattern with your I and
your Co okay so uh and your Marshall
components so when I uh clear the line
for example like this I am in his zon
sanctuary and that collection of his
elbow has generated an angle cancel
ation on the other arm the cross lateral
arm okay so there you can attack and
things like that
okay so as I as I go into that elbow and
collect it then you are now in in an
adhesion you're working that adhesion to
get him to go that
way so now you combine again martially
your angle of deflection is contrasted
with your angle of deviation is
deflected to the left and I deviate to
the right okay and that is your
Technique okay that first
part right when he goes in he's going to
go left I'm going to go to the right for
example in
eel okay and then the elbow pattern
again so collect there's the part that I
want move yourself so that his arm does
not
extend and then add the C to that
aspect R and the C is not going to be
where I just do the pattern but where I
feel his Center so I'm moving his
[Music]
Center in B
Center and again the claw is your power
source
oh
[Music]
okay your job with this this drill is
to it's not going to be any different
name your your your task is divine
communion there's a pattern to it
because there's an energetic value to it
you can't just do
whatever is it if your goal is how do I
just uh knock how do I just there's a
million ways that you could push him
over do you get it there's not a million
ways for divine communion there's not
there's not okay so as as I'm going this
way and then if I go I just want to push
him over and I change that pattern then
it's not going to do what I want it to
do
ultimately okay I my goal is not to make
you go away
from you're just a
metric really what you are is a
test you're you're a test you're a
stressor that's going to induce the ego
tripartite mind and your whole skill is
skill of bringing a sensation to it well
we're going to attempt it then to
continue functioning and will you now
not use it that's the thing that's all
you are you're you're you're a you're
like a stripper you get it like you're
trying to entice me you're trying to
lure me but no
no demon no okay so I just keep my
shape you're not pulling my mind nor my
[Music]
body
I just keep my shape you got it he I
don't let him pull me and go must throw
him instead must keep
shape got it do you guys understand that
that's my goal try it again